Let me start by reviewing the problem that we were considering last week.
Yeah.
We were raising a difficulty for the personality theory of personal identity
according to which the key to being the same person is having the very same
ongoing,
evolving personality and,
and the difficulty was brace basically the problem of duplication that it seemed
as though we could have more than one,
call it an individual more than one body that had the very same set of memories,
beliefs and so forth.
And then we'd have to ask ourselves,
well,
what should the personality theory say about a case like that?
So imagine that over the weekend,
uh,
the mad scientist copied my memories,
beliefs,
desires,
fears,
ambitions,
goals,
intentions,
and imprinted that on somebody else's brain.
They did it last night at midnight this morning we woke up and we have to ask
ourselves,
who's Shelly Kagan?
Who's the person that was lecturing to you last week?
Well,
it doesn't seem plausible in terms of the personality theory to say that he's
Shelly Kagan and the one here today.
You know,
suppose the other one's in,
in Michigan,
right?
If the one in Michigan,
Shelly Kagan,
but this one's not after all though.
It's true.
He's got Shelly Kagan's memories.
Yeah.
He woke up thinking he was Charlotte Kagan.
Just like I woke up thinking I was Shelly Kagan.
He woke up thinking about what he was going to lecture on it in class today.
Just like I woke up thinking about what I was going to lecture in class today.
He remembered last week's lecture just like I remembered last week's lecture.
Well,
no clear reason to say for the personality theory to say that he's Shelly Kagan
and I'm not,
after all,
I've got the very same set of memories,
beliefs,
desires that he has,
but equally true and more surprisingly from the personality theory point of
view,
there's no reason to say that I'm Shelly Kagan and he's not,
after all,
he's got all the same memories,
beliefs and desires that I do
doesn't seem plausible to say we're both Shelly Kagan because now we'd have to
then say Shelly Kagan's in two places at the same time.
So the only alternative seems to me to say that neither of us is Shelly Kagan.
Okay.
But if neither of us is Shelly Kagan,
then the simple original personality theory was false because according to that
theory,
having the personality is what it took to be.
Shelly Kagan,
we both have it yet.
Neither of us is Shelly Kagan.
Personality theory must be false,
so we revise the personality theory to say the secret to personal identity is
having the same personality provided that there's no branching provided.
There's no splitting provided is only one best competitor not to equally good
candidates.
Given the no branching view,
the no branching rule we can say in the ordinary case law,
you know,
look,
there really wasn't anybody in printed with my,
with my memories and desires in Michigan.
I'm the only one around in the earth right now with with Shelly Kagan's memories
and desires since there's no competitor and I've got the personality I Michella
Kagan,
I'm the very same person that was here lecturing to you last week.
That's what the personality theory,
it gives us the answer we're looking for in the ordinary case.
But in the science fiction story where there's a duplicate,
it says if there's branching,
the no branch in rule comes in.
Neither of them is Shelly Kagan.
All right,
so that's the best way for the personality theory to get revised to deal with
this problem.
The trouble was it seems for no branching rules.
Seems very counter intuitive.
So think about it here,
right now I'm standing in front of you saying,
I'm Shelly Kagan,
the guy who was lecturing to you last week,
I believe.
I'm Shelly Kagan,
the guy who was lecturing to you last week.
Am I Shelly Kagan?
Well,
I've got Shelly Kagan's personality.
So far,
so good.
Now all we have to decide is what is the branching rules satisfied are violated.
So all we have to know is,
is there somebody else somewhere in the universe who's got all my memories and
beliefs and desires?
Well,
how in the world could I know that
whether I,
this person talking to you right now is Shelly Kagan.
Depends on whether there is some duplicate with all my memories in Michigan or
not.
Seems very counterintuitive.
So although the personality with no branching rule avoids the problem of what to
say about duplicates by saying when there's branching,
neither of them.
Shelly Kagan,
the branching rule itself seems very counterintuitive.
We feel as though whether somebody is me or not should depend upon internal
facts about me in the earlier stages or this stage and that stage,
not about what's happening elsewhere outside extrinsic to these things.
Now do you know,
so if you're not willing to accept the no branch rule,
if it strikes you as a bizarre thing to throw into personal identity,
maybe you need to reject the personality theory.
Now,
during all of this,
the fans of the body view typically are laughing.
They say,
you know,
this just goes to show what a dumb theory.
The personality theory is.
The whole problem with the personality theory is that personality is a bit like
a software.
It's like programs,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's the,
it's the various programs you run on your computer along with the various data
files that have saved on your hard drive and so forth,
and those can be duplicated.
You have copy after copy after copy.
You could have two copies of my personality.
You can have a hundred or a thousand.
The problem with the,
you know,
what drove the personality theory into the no branching rule implausible is,
it may be was the fact that your personality is like software and it can be
copied.
That's why they say we should believe in the body view.
We accept the body view.
We avoid the duplication problem because unlike software,
which we complicate,
which can be literally copied as many as you want,
identical,
the body can't split,
human bodies can't divide or branch.
There's no way that there's another body that the body,
I'm Thursday became two bodies.
The body that was here on Thursday didn't,
couldn't become two bodies.
So we avoid all the problem.
That's,
that's at least the kind of claim that fans of the body view often make in the
face of this difficulty for the personality theory.
Yeah,
well now we need to ask,
is it really true?
Is it really true that bodies don't face a duplication problem?
Is it really true that human bodies don't and couldn't split look crucial
warriors of course couldn't.
Personalities don't actually split either,
right?
Although I've been giving science fiction examples in which the mad scientist
duplicates my memories and beliefs and desires.
They are all been science fiction examples.
If I can use science fiction to talk about the possibility of splitting and use
that against the personality theory,
I'm entitled to use science fiction examples to talk about the possibility of
bodies splitting and ask what kind of problem that would raise for the body
theory.
Now we are familiar with some low level examples of bodies splitting Amoebas
split,
right?
You got all a single Amoeba.
It's going along at a certain point.
Let's draw our AMOEBA splitting,
right?
You've got an Amoeba split going along at a certain point,
start to look like that
and it looks like that
and then boom,
you got,
well,
it splits.
There's nothing in sort of biology per se that rules out cell division.
Indeed on the contrary,
right?
We know cells can split.
Now human bodies,
unlike Amoebas,
don't do that,
but maybe there's nothing in biology that rules out the possibility.
It's opposed.
We open up the Yale daily tomorrow and we see that the Yale Center for Amoebic
Studies has made this tremendous breakthrough and has discovered how to,
you know,
through the right kind of injection or whatever cause a human body to replicate
and split in an Amoeba like fashion.
Okay,
well then we have to face the problem of what to say in this case of bodily
branching.
Well set up pursuing that example.
Let me give you a slightly different example that's been discussed a fair bit in
the philosophical literature.
This is actually a case that one of the students in the class asked about,
you know,
I think it was last week if it wasn't even earlier and he said,
great question,
let's come back to it.
So here at long last,
I'm making good on my promissory note.
I'm going to come back to the example that was raised before.
You'll recall that when we talked about the body of you,
I said,
the best version of the body view doesn't require the entire body to be the same
body,
but the brain follow the brain.
And Indiana doesn't seem as though we have to require the entire brain,
just enough of the brain,
however much that turns out to house,
personality,
memories and so forth.
And then I said,
suppose it was possible that one hemisphere of your brain is enough if there's
enough redundancy in the brain.
Okay.
So that even if your right hemisphere got destroyed,
your left hemisphere,
you still have all the same memories,
desires,
beliefs.
Good enough.
Okay,
so now we worry about the following case.
So I gave you a bunch of examples,
right?
Where there are brains being transplanted into torsos of others too,
I suppose gruesome as it was.
I was in,
um,
you know,
this weekend I'm in some horrible accident and my torso gets destroyed and they
keep my brain on life support,
oxygenating it just long enough to do some radical surgery.
Yeah.
Into some spare torsos where the torso come from.
Well,
you had some living people,
but they had very rare brain diseases and their brain suddenly liquified.
So now we've got some spare torsos.
All right,
so here we've got
Shelly Kagan.
Body gets destroyed.
Here's my brain
over here we've got
Jones,
his torso,
and over here we've got Smith's torso.
Suppose we take
call this one the left hemisphere,
and we stick it in here
into Jones,
his torso.
We take this other hemisphere of Mike,
Right half of my brain,
okay,
we stick it into Smith's torso.
Connect all the wires,
all the neurons,
the operations,
a smashing success.
Both things wake up.
So here's John Jones,
his torso with the left half of us ks,
Brain Smith's torso with the right half of best case brain,
they wake up.
We need some way to refer to these people so we can start talking about who they
are.
Let me just call this top one.
Jones his torso with the left half of Shelly Kagan,
his brain.
It's called him lefty
Smith's torso with the right half of Shelly Kagan's brain.
It's called them righty.
Okay.
Operations is a success.
Lefty and righty both.
Wake up,
they both think they're Shelly Kagan,
so forth and so on.
We ask ourselves,
according to the body view,
which one is Shelly Kagan,
what are the possibilities?
We could say lefty is Shelly Kagan and Riley is not right.
He's an imposter,
but there's nothing in the body view to give us a reason to make that choice.
It's true that left,
he's got half a Shelly Kagan's brain and that's good enough.
But it's also true that right,
he's got half of Shelly Kagan's brain and that seemed good enough.
So there's no reason to say that lefties,
Shelly Kagan and right,
he isn't.
And similarly of course there's nothing in the body view to make us say that
writing Shelly Kagan and lefty isn't,
well,
it's not one and not the other one.
Are they remaining all possibilities?
We could,
I suppose try to say they're both Shelly Kagan
and so Shelly Kagan continues.
That is to say his body continues.
That is to say his brain continues.
That is to say nothing of his brain continues merrily on its way,
except now in two places.
And so from now on,
Shelly Kagan,
that single person is in two different places at the same time.
You know,
lefty goes to California,
writing moves to Vermont from now on.
Shelly Kagan's by coastal
doesn't seem right.
So what else can the body theory say?
Well the body theory could say neither of them are Shelly Kagan.
Shelly Kagan died in that gruesome horrible accident.
Although it's true that we now have two people,
lefty and Righty,
each of whom has half and Shelly Kagan's brain and all of Shelly Kagan's
memories for whatever that's worth.
Neither of them is Shelly Kagan.
We could say that as well.
But if we end,
that seems the least on palatable of the alternatives.
But if we say that,
then we've given up on the body view because the body view after all said to be
Shelly Kagan is to have enough of Shelly Kagan's brain and in this case both of
lefties and righties seem to have enough of Shelly Kagan's brain.
What's the body theorist to do?
As far as I can see.
The best option for the body theorist at this point is to add no surprises here.
Uh,
no branching rule.
The body theorists would say the key to personal identities having the same body
too at the same brain to it.
I'm not for the brain to keep the third personality going,
provided that there's no branching,
no splitting,
no perfect competitors.
Only one
if the body view ad the no branching principal,
then we can say look,
in the case of this sort of splitting,
this example is known in the philosophical literature as fishermen like nuclear
fission when a big Adam splits into two.
So in the fusion case,
the body says the body theorist says,
and the fission case,
there's splitting this branching.
So neither of them is going to end up being Shelly Kagan but in the ordinary hum
drum case,
no,
here I am,
my body.
Why am I Shelly Kagan?
Because the brain in front of you can't see it,
but it's in front of you.
The brain in front of you is the very same brain as the brain.
You know that you had in front of you on Thursday.
Follow the body in particular,
follow the brain.
So in the ordinary case,
no splitting.
Follow the brain in the special case where they're splitting,
even if they follow the brain,
not good enough.
So the
okay
body theorist can avoid the problem of fision.
Avoid the problem of duplication by adding the no branching rule.
But of course,
no,
no branching rule didn't seem very intuitive.
You know,
whether or not I'm Shelly Kagan,
the guy that was lecturing to you on Thursday,
depends on whether unbeknownst to me over the weekend somebody removed,
half of my brain's stuck in some other torso sealed me all back up.
How could that matter?
Well,
if you don't find a no branching rule plausible,
you're in trouble as a body theorist.
In fact.
So what we see is the body theory isn't exactly the same problem.
Exactly the same situation as the personality theory.
Indeed.
The fision example is a very nice case of how you could have,
yeah,
splitting for the personality theory.
Right here before the accident was Shelly Kagan,
somebody who had my beliefs,
desires,
memories,
goals,
and so forth.
After the accident we've got two people,
lefty and righty or two entities,
lefty and Righty,
both of whom Shelly have Shelly Kagan's,
memories,
beliefs,
desires,
goals and so forth.
Splitting the brain shows how you could in fact have splitting of personality.
So the very same case raises the very same problem for both the body view and
the personality view.
And the only solution that I can see,
oh,
he's the best solution that I can see is to accept the no branching rule.
If you don't like to know branching rule,
it's not clear what your alternatives are.
Yeah.
Or at least it is clear what your alternatives are.
It's not clear which alternative it would be any better.
Now during all of this problem for the personality theory problems for the body
view during all this,
the soul theorist is having a field day.
Alright?
This soul theorist is saying,
look,
you guys,
you got into all this trouble with splitting and so forth and so on and needing
to add the no branch in rule silly and implausible is that seems you got into
all that trouble cause of the problem of splitting because personalities can be
split,
bodies can be split.
If only you had seen the light and stuck to the sole theory of personal
identity,
all of these problems could be avoided.
Okay.
Now as you know,
I don't believe in souls,
but forget that issue for the moment.
Let's just ask the question.
Is it true that the sole theory of only the worst souls,
is it true that the sole theory would at least have the following advantage it
avoid these problems of duplication and vision?
Well,
let's ask,
what should a soul theorist say about the vision case?
So here's the gruesome accident.
My brain gets split apart.
One part gets put into Jones,
his torso.
One Park gets put into Smith's torso after the operation,
lefty wakes up thinking he's Shelly Kagan.
Smith wakes up thinking he's Shelly Kagan lefties got part of Jelly Kagan's
brain smiths.
Oh rather,
right?
He's got part of Shelly Kagan's brain.
What should the sole theorist say about the case of vision?
Well,
again,
remember the sole theory says the Kenan being the same person is having the
soul.
You know,
why am I the person that was lecturing to you on Thursday because it's the very
same soul animating my body or what have you.
Yeah,
so what does the soul theorists say about the fusion case?
Not quite sure because we have to turn to a metaphysical question that we've
touched upon before.
Namely,
can souls split
after all we've done the problem that vision raises for the personality theory
in a,
in a nutshell is it personalities can split,
they can branch.
The problem for the body view that vision raises in a nutshell is that bodies
can split.
They can branch.
We need to ask about the metaphysics of the soul.
Can Souls Split?
And I don't know the answer to that of course.
So let's consider both possibilities.
Possibility number one,
souls just like bodies,
just like personalities can split.
So it was,
that's what happened.
So there was a single soul here,
Shelly Kagan's soul,
but in the middle of this gruesome operation,
gruesome,
accurate,
and fall by this amazing operation.
Shelly Kagan's soul split.
So there's one of the s k soles over here and there's one of the Ska souls
and the other cases as well.
Each one of lefty and righty has one of the pieces of the split,
Shelly Kagan soul.
All right,
so now we ask ourselves,
according to the sole theory,
which one is Shelly Kagan?
Well,
you by this point you can run through all the possibilities yourself,
right?
We could say,
well,
it's lefty and not writing,
but there's nothing in the sole theory that's supports that claim they've
gotten.
They each have an equally good,
however good it may be.
They've got an equally good piece of the original Shelly Kagan's soul.
Cause no reason to say that lefty is Shelly Kagan it right?
He isn't.
No good reason to say,
righty.
Shelly Kagan and lefty isn't,
well,
would it be better to say they're both Shelly Kagan as long as you got a piece
of Shelly Kagan's soul of the original soul.
Then you just are Shelly Kagan.
Which case left righty are both Shelly Kagan and Shelly Kagan is now by coastal
one in California,
one in Vermont.
Okay.
One part of him that doesn't seem very satisfying.
What's the alternative?
The alternative,
it seems for the sole theorist is to say neither of them is Shelly Kagan.
Neither of them is Shelly Kagan.
Then Shelly Kagan died,
but how can we say that if we accept the sole theory,
they both have pieces of Shelly Kagan sole,
the sole split.
Okay,
well maybe what the soul theorists would have to do at this point is except that
the no branching rule,
ah,
says the soul theorist follow the soul and less the sole splits,
in which case neither of them Miss Shelly Kagan.
Okay,
well trouble is we didn't find the no branch in rule very plausible.
It seems counter intuitive,
but at this point you begin to wonder,
maybe we just need to learn to live with it.
If the personality theory needs the no branching rule and the body theory needs
to know branching rule and the sole theory needs the no branch in rule,
maybe we'll just stuck with the no branching rule whether or not we like it.
Yeah,
and if we're stuck with it,
then of course it's not an objection against any one of the theories that it
uses it.
Well.
This was all what we would say as sole theorist if we think souls can split,
but we need to consider the possibility that soul can't split,
namely the sole theorist has an alternative available to it that available to
him that the other theories don't have.
Suppose Shelly Kagan's soul cannot split.
What does that mean?
It means when my brain gets split,
my soul is going to end up in lefty or righty,
but not in both.
Solo can't split,
can't end up with pieces of the soul or the remnants of the soul in both the
souls.
That unified simple thing.
Now.
I don't actually know whether it's true.
That's simple.
Things can't split metaphysically.
I'm not sure where that's a possibility or not,
but let's just suppose,
look,
Plato argued to soul was simple.
He didn't actually convince me of that,
but supposedly thought souls are simple and we think simple things can't split.
It would follow.
Then it falls can't split.
Supposedly we accept all that metaphysics.
Then the question is just which one is Shelly Kagan?
Well,
it depends which one ended up with Shelly Kagan's soul.
We can't say they both have a piece.
One of them will have it.
The other one won't
and you want to know which ones?
Shelly Kagan,
the one that actually ends up with Shelly Kagan soul.
If lefty ends up with Shelly Kagan's soul,
then lefty is Shelly Kagan and righties and imposter.
Okay.
He thinks he Shelly Kagan,
but he's not because he doesn't have Shelly Kagan soul.
Lefty has it
if right.
He's got Shelly Kagan's soul.
Then righty is Shelly Kagan and lefties the imposter.
Now
looking at the situation from the outside,
we might be unable to tell which one is really Shelly Kagan because we won't be
able to tell.
Looking at it from the outside,
which one really has Shelly Kagan soul,
although it will be true,
which everyone really does have.
Shelly Kagan soul is Shelly Kagan,
but we don't know which one that is.
Interestingly,
and somewhat more surprisingly,
looking at it from the inside,
we won't be able to tell either lefty.
We'll say gimme a break.
Of course.
I'm Shelly Kagan.
Oh,
of course.
I've got Shelly Kagan's soul.
Of course,
I'm the one,
but righty.
We'll also say gimme a break.
Of course.
I'm Shelly Kagan.
I've got Shelly Kagan soul.
Of course I'm the one is souls can't split.
One of them is mistaken,
but there's no way for them to know which one is the one that's deceived.
No,
that may not be a problem that you're unwilling to swallow.
Right?
As we've seen all the views here have their difficulties.
Maybe that's the difficulty.
You're prepared to accept.
What's the right answer in vision?
It depends on who's got Shelly Kagan's soul.
No way to tell,
but still,
that's the answer to the metaphysical question question.
What
question was what if neither of these
have Shelly Kagan soul?
Then they're both imposters.
That's a little bit like the pace we worried about when we started thinking
about the soul view,
right?
What if last night God destroyed my soul and put in a new soul man,
Charlie Kagan died.
If
Shelly Kagan's soul does not migrate to lefty or Righty,
neither,
the Michelli Kagan according to the sole theory,
what happened to Shelly Kagan?
Well,
if the sole got destroyed,
Shelly Kagan died.
If the sole didn't get destroyed,
maybe somebody else that we weren't even looking at is Shelly Kagan.
So as I say,
this sole theory can at least give us an answer that avoid the no branching rule
is souls are simples and simples can't split.
There was no possibility of having two things with the relevant soul.
So we don't need to add in in this sort of ad hoc fashion,
the no branching rule.
Okay.
That's an advantage for the sole theory.
If only we believed in souls.
It is an advantage,
but I need to point out that there's another disadvantage that the fishing case
raises for the sole theory.
So let's just suppose that metaphysically God tells us that it's lefty that has
Shelly Kagan's soul.
Then of course it's lefty.
That is Shelly Kagan.
Righty is an imposter,
righty believes he's Shelly Kagan.
He has all the memories of Shelly Kagan,
all the desires or Shelly Kagan,
but he's not showy Kagan because he doesn't have Shelly Kagan soul left.
He happens to have it.
Yeah,
that's a nice answer to the problem of vision.
But notice the problem raises for the argument for believing in a soul in the
first place.
Way Back at the start of the semester when we asked why believe in souls,
one important argument was you need a really family of arguments was you need to
believe in souls in order to explain why bodies are animated,
why people are rational,
how'd they can have personalities,
how they can be creative and so forth.
In order to explain consciousness and self awareness,
whatever it was,
filling your favorite,
your favorite blank,
you'll fill in the blank.
And your favorite way the claim was you needed to believe in souls.
Know to explain all that.
Yeah,
but if that's right,
what's going on in Riley's case,
righty is aware,
right?
Is Conscious,
He is creative,
right?
He has free will,
He makes plans,
right?
He's got personality.
Righty is rational righties body is animated according to the sole theory
argument for salt,
whether call me the argument for souls.
He needed to believe in souls and order new.
Explain how you could have a person
but now,
right,
he's a person without a soul cause we just hypothesized all Shelly Kagan soul up
there.
So at the very same moment,
that positive in the non splitting of souls seems to solve the fision problem of
duplication.
It Yank the rug out from underneath the sole theorist by undermining one of the
types of arguments for believing in the soul in the first place.
After all,
if Riney can be our person,
admittedly not Shelly Kagan,
but a person conscious,
creative,
rational,
so far aware without a soul,
then maybe same thing's true for us,
which is the question is what the physicalist says.
Let me mention one other possibility cause it's quite intriguing.
It's the Saul theorist answers that last objection by saying eight ever gone to
happen?
Yeah.
It would be a problem for believing in souls if right.
He could wake up without one,
but since we stipulated that Shelly Kagan soul is going to end up in lefty,
righty is not going to wake up.
Okay.
Alternatively,
it might've been that righty woke up,
but lefty doesn't wake up,
doesn't survive the operation.
Okay.
Suppose we did the sort of brain transfers all the time and the following thing
always happened.
Transfer the entire brain.
Patient wakes up,
transfer one hemisphere,
patient wakes up,
transfer both hemispheres.
One patient or the other wakes up but never both.
If that happened,
we'd have a great new argument for the existence of a soul.
What could possibly explain why either hemisphere,
that brain would normally be enough as long as we don't transfer both when we
transfer both one hemisphere might work sometimes,
sometimes the other hemisphere,
but never both.
What could possibly explain that soul's could explain that if souls can't split,
it can only follow one half of the brain and that's why we'll never,
we'll get some just get one half,
sometimes the other half,
but never both halfs.
So there's a kind of empirical argument for the existence of the soul if we
found those kinds of results.
Of course that's a big F,
you know?
Please don't go away thinking that.
What I've just said is here's a new argument for the soul.
We don't do brain transfers,
let alone half a half a brain.
We don't have any experiments that suggest one half wakes up but not the other
half.
All I'm saying is that if some day we found that at that point we'd have an
argument for the soul.
Well again,
let me put back the put away the sole theory again,
I was exploring it because it's interesting to think about its implications,
but since I don't believe in souls,
I want to choose between the body view and the personality view.
Both of them as we saw in the face of fision needs to accept a no branching
rule.
If they're gonna survive this thinking about this case at all,
we need to throw in a no branching rule whether or not you find the no branch in
rule,
hard to believe.
If both views are stuck with it,
well then we're stuck with it.
So let's try to choose between the personality theory with the no branch in rule
and the body theory with the no branch in rule.
Which of these should we accept?
Which of these is the better theory of personal identity?
Answer,
I'm not sure.
Over the course of my philosophical career,
I have moved back and forth between them.
There are certainly a long period of time in which I found the personality
theory that is personality theory with the no branching rule to be the better
and more plausible theory.
And it certainly has any number of advocates on the contemporary philosophical
scene.
But at other times in my philosophical career,
I have found the body theory that is to say the body theory with the no
branching rule to be the more plausible theory.
And it is certainly the case that the body theory has its advocates among
contemporary philosophers.
Okay
for what it's worth and I don't actually think that when I'm about to say is
worth all that much.
I'm going to share with you my own pet belief these days.
I'm inclined to go with the body theory.
I'm inclined to think that the key to personal identities,
having the same body as long as there's no branching,
as long as there's no splitting,
but
certainly open to you to decide that you think no,
no.
The personality theories,
the stronger view.
Okay.
I can't settle the question.
I don't have any more philosophical arguments up my sleeve on this issue,
but I do have another point that's worth considering.
Although I'm inclined to think that the body theory may be the best view about
what's the key to personal identity.
I'm also inclined to think it doesn't really matter.
Okay.
We've been posing the following question we've been asking what does it take for
it to be true that I survive?
Yeah,
and it may be that what we should conclude is whatever.
The best answer to that question is,
it's not the question we should really have been thinking about.
We weren't going to be in a position to see that until we went through all the
stuff we've been going over for the last couple of weeks.
But now that we're here,
we're in a position perhaps to raise the question,
should we be asking what it takes to survive or should we be asking about what
matters in survival now and posing this question,
I'm obviously presupposing that we can draw a distinction between the question,
do I survive?
Is somebody that existed in the future,
whatever me and the question,
what is,
what was it that I wanted when I wanted to survive?
What was it that mattered in ordinary survival?
Yeah,
and it might be that these things can actually come apart to see this.
Suppose we start by thinking again about the soul view.
Suppose there are souls,
I don't believe in them,
but let's imagine suppose there are souls and compose that souls are the key to
personal identity.
So somebody is me,
if they've got my soul or to put it more straight forwardly you know,
next week the person that's me is the person with my soul.
I survive as long as there's somebody around with my soul,
hundred years from now,
am I still around?
Well,
if my soul still around,
that's me.
That's what the sole theory says,
and suppose it's the truth.
Okay.
Now consider the following possibility.
Suppose that people can be reincarnated.
That is to say at the death of their body,
their soul takes over,
animates and habits gets connected to a new body that's being born.
But unlike the kind of reincarnation cases that get talked about in popular
culture and various religions where at least under the right circumstances,
you can remember your prior lives.
Let's imagine that when the soul is reincarnated,
it's scrubbed,
completely clean,
no traces whatsoever of the life,
no way to retrieve it,
no karmic similarities of personality or anything just starts over like a blank
slate like,
like on blackboard that's been completely erased.
We now have the very same blackboard and how we start writing new things on it.
I imagine that that's the way reincarnation worked.
So somebody asked you,
will you still be around in a thousand years?
The answer's gonna be yes,
because my soul will be reincarnated in a thousand years.
There'll be somebody that has the very same soul that's animating my body right
now.
Of course,
that's soul won't remember being Shelly Kagan won't have any memories of its
prior life.
It won't be like Shelly Kagan in any way.
In terms of Shelly Kagan's desires or ambitions or goals or fears,
it won't be that.
We can sort of see why that personality emerges through Karmic cause and effect
in any ways that are a function of what my,
I was liken my life.
It'll be Shelly Kagan because it's Shelly Kagan's soul,
but with no overlap of personality,
memories,
anything.
Then I want to say,
who cares?
The fact that I will survive under those circumstances doesn't give me anything
that matters to me.
Yeah.
It's no comfort to me to be told I will survive because after all,
the soul is the key to personal identity.
If there's no similar personality,
no memories,
no beliefs,
no retrievable memories of past lives,
then who cares that it's me.
If you can feel the force of that thought,
then you're seeing how the question will I survive,
can be separated out from the question,
what matters?
What do we care about?
Bear survival of my soul,
even though that is the key to personal identity,
if it is bare survival of my soul doesn't give me what I want,
it's it's no more comforting or satisfying than if you said no.
You know this knuckle bone after you die who go on to do knuckle bone surgery
and implant that knuckle bone in somebody else's body and that knuckle bone is
gone to survive.
I said,
oh,
that's very interesting that that knuckle bone will be around a hundred or a
thousand years from now,
but who cares?
And if the knuckle bone theory of personal identity gets proposed and somebody
says,
Oh yes,
but you see that person now would that knuckle boom will be you?
Because the key to personal identities having the very same knuckle bone,
I say all so it's me.
Who Cares?
Yeah,
bare knuckle bones survival does not give me what matters.
Now the knuckle bone theory of personal identity is a very stupid theory.
In contrast,
the sole theory of personal survival is not a stupid theory,
but for all that,
it doesn't give me what I want.
When you think about the possibility of bear survival of the scrubbed clean
array soul,
you see that survival wasn't really everything you wanted,
what you wanted,
at least what I want,
I invite you to ask yourself whether you want the same thing.
What I want is not just survival,
but survival with the same personality.
So even if the sole theory is the correct theory of personality,
it's not enough to get me what matters.
What matters isn't just survival.
It's survival with the same personality.
Okay?
Let's consider the body view.
Suppose that the body theory of personal identity is correct,
and to be me,
it's gotta be somebody there that's got my body.
Let's suppose the brain version of the theory is the best version.
And so next year there's gonna be somebody that's got my brain.
But let's imagine that the brain has been scrubbed clean.
All memory traces have been completely erased.
We're talking complete irreversible amnesia,
complete a ratio of the brain's hard drive.
No traces of desires and memories and intentions to be and beliefs to eventually
be recovered.
If only we have the right surgery or procedure or psychotherapy,
what have you,
it's gone now.
That thing that wakes up after this complete irreversible amnesia,
we'll no doubt eventually develop a personality set of beliefs,
memories.
Nobody knows who it is.
So they called,
you know,
I find it wandering on the streets.
They call it John Doe.
John Doe will eventually have a bunch of beliefs about how the world works.
Make some plans,
get some memories according to the body theory.
That's me.
Yeah.
And if the body here is correct,
well by Golly,
it is me.
And all I can say in response to that is it's me,
but who cares?
So what?
I'm not comforted by the thought that I will still be around 50 years from now.
If the thing that's me doesn't have my personality
mirror,
bodily survival isn't enough to give me what I want.
I want more than mere bodily survival.
I want to survive with this same personality.
Yeah.
So even if the body theory of personal identity is the right theory,
what I want to say in response to that is,
so what if the really crucial question is not,
do I survive,
but do I have what I wanted when I wanted to survive?
The answer is the body theory doesn't give it.
I don't just want to survive.
I want to survive with the same personality.
Should we conclude therefore that the key to the important question,
namely what matters?
The answer to that question should we conclude,
is same personality.
That's the question we'll have to take up next time.